Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter One, Episode 2, Part Two.
Now, trouble in the south.
In the first half of the 1800s, national consciousness grew in Europe, including in Denmark.
So did the conflict between those who felt Danish and those who felt German in the Danish kingdom.
In 1848 to 50 this triggered a civil war between the Kingdom of Denmark and German-minded rebels in the duchies of Schleswig and Holstein, where the Danish king was also ruler.
Denmark won the war at first, but the problem was not solved.
In 1864, the national tensions again triggered a war.
This time the Germans won, and Denmark lost both Schleswig and Holstein.
Let's go through it carefully.
In the middle of the 1800s, the Danish composite state, the helstat, consisted of the Danish kingdom and the duchies of Schleswig and Holstein.
The Danish king ruled in all three parts of the realm.
The increased national feeling and democratic ideas created tension between the Danish-speaking and the German-speaking parts of the population.
The population in Holstein was German, and most Danish politicians saw it as natural that the Holsteiners wanted to break away from Denmark and join the German Confederation.
But in Schleswig there were both Danish speakers, who wanted to remain part of Denmark, and German-speaking inhabitants, who wanted to break away and join the German Confederation together with Holstein.
This was called the Schleswig problem.
People and politicians on both sides of the border discussed where the Danish border should run.
In 1848, Schleswig and Holstein were refused their demand for an independent free constitution.
On the other hand, it was clear that Denmark wanted the Danish constitution, which was on its way, to also apply to Schleswig, which would then be united with Denmark but separated from Holstein.
These conflicting wishes led to war between Schleswig and Holstein rebels on one side and Denmark on the other.
The German Confederation and the strongest of the German states, Prussia, backed the rebels and sent a large number of soldiers into the war on the side of the duchies.
In 1849 Denmark and the Schleswig-Holsteiners fought a series of battles.
One was at Fredericia in July, where the Danish army was victorious.
In 1850, the German Confederation and Prussia were pressured by Russia to withdraw their auxiliary troops from the conflict.
Afterwards the Danish army won a series of decisive victories, among others at Isted in July 1850.
It was the bloodiest battle of the war, with thousands of dead and wounded.
After mediation by the European great powers, the result was that the two duchies would continue to be part of the Danish composite state.
That solution would prove not to last long.
The three-year war from 1848 to 50 is also called the First Schleswig War.
Then came the Second.
After the First Schleswig War, Denmark had promised the great powers that Denmark would not bind Schleswig closer to itself than Holstein.
But Denmark broke its promise.
In 1863, pressed by public opinion, the Danish Rigsdag adopted a new joint constitution for both Denmark and Schleswig, but not for Holstein.
The German states saw the Danish-Schleswig constitution as a breach of the agreement that had been made.
Prussia, whose political leader was the powerful prime minister Otto von Bismarck, therefore declared war on Denmark together with Austria in February 1864.
This war is called the Second Schleswig War.
Unlike the First Schleswig War in 1848 to 50, this time Denmark did not get help from the European great powers.
Denmark was attacked from the south, and the Danish forces expected that Dannevirke would protect them against the attack.
Dannevirke was a defensive structure which, since the Viking Age, had been a strong line of defence.
But in February 1864, the Danish army had to be evacuated in great haste from Dannevirke, because the opponents outnumbered them.
Parts of the Danish army withdrew north into Jutland.
But the main part of the soldiers held the defensive position at Dybbøl, near Sønderborg.
On the eighteenth of April, the Prussians attacked Dybbøl after a long bombardment, and the inferior Danish forces were defeated.
All of Jutland was occupied by enemy forces, and when the Prussians at the end of June also conquered the island of Als, the Danish politicians had to realise that the war was lost.
The defeat in 1864 was a catastrophe for Denmark.
Denmark had to cede Schleswig, Holstein and the small duchy of Lauenburg to Prussia and Austria.
The Danish king had at a stroke lost about two fifths of his population and one third of his territory, which afterwards consisted of Denmark proper, plus a number of sparsely populated lands: Greenland, the Faroe Islands and Iceland, and, until 1917, the three small Danish West Indian islands.
So after 1864 the kingdom had a more uniform population than ever before.
The great majority of the population spoke the same language, had the same constitution, and were culturally quite alike, though there was still a great difference between rich and poor.
In the adversity after the defeat in 1864, the Danish national identity grew even stronger, and language and culture came to mean a lot.
Many South Jutlanders now lived in the German empire south of the border, but felt Danish.
Only in 1920 were the Danish-minded areas in the northern part of Schleswig reunited with Denmark.
And what did the defeat mean for Denmark's place in the world?
The war and the loss of the duchies in 1864 meant that Denmark was now unconditionally reduced to a small state with no influence on the decisions of the European great powers.
In 1871, Bismarck had gathered the German states into a strong empire, and Denmark now stood completely in the shadow of its large neighbour to the south.
There was now great concern that Denmark would be wiped out as an independent state.
To secure its continued survival, Denmark tried at almost any price to avoid involvement in international conflicts.
In security policy, Denmark afterwards chose to be strictly neutral, and maintained only a weak military defence.
So here is the quick recap for Episode Two.
Norway was in union with Denmark from 1380 to 1814, over four hundred years.
The stavnsbånd limited the peasants' freedom to move.
Under the 1849 constitution, women had no vote.
Colonies: Tranquebar and Serampore in India, forts in Ghana, and the West Indian islands, sold to the USA in 1917.
The slave trade was banned from 1803, and slavery ended in 1848.
The stavnsbånd came in 1733, and was abolished from 1788.
Struensee governed from 1770 to 72.
The Battle of the Roads was in 1801, the Bombardment of Copenhagen in 1807, and Norway was lost in 1814.
The constitution was signed on the fifth of June, 1849.
The First Schleswig War ran from 1848 to 50, and the Second in 1864, with the defeat at Dybbøl on the eighteenth of April.
In Episode Three, Denmark modernises.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which historical event took place in 1864?
Option A: Denmark lost the Second Schleswig War.
Option B: Denmark got its first Social Democratic prime minister.
Option C: Danish women got the vote for the Folketing.
[DA] Hvilken historisk begivenhed fandt sted i 1864?  A: Danmark tabte Den 2. Slesvigske Krig  |  B: Danmark fik sin første socialdemokratiske statsminister  |  C: Danske kvinder fik valgret til Folketinget
The answer is A: Denmark lost the Second Schleswig War.
It appeared in the June 2021 and November 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Danmark tabte Den 2. Slesvigske Krig
Question 2.
What was the result of the Second Schleswig War in 1864?
Option A: Denmark conquered Schleswig.
Option B: Denmark lost Schleswig.
[DA] Hvad blev resultatet af Den 2. Slesvigske Krig i 1864?  A: Danmark erobrede Slesvig  |  B: Danmark tabte Slesvig
The answer is B: Denmark lost Schleswig.
It appeared in the May 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Danmark tabte Slesvig
That's the end of this part.
Well done.